alors président c'est vous présenter
monsieur fatale qui désormais avant on
avait un mage et maintenant on a on a
choisi eric monsieur patate qui tirent
les tarots à la nos invités principaux
chaque semaine
alors la question à laquelle je voudrais
que les cartes répondre mon cher eric
c'est parce que le président bourges va
revenir à la télévision dans les mois
qui viennent ah si si si c'est
d'ailleurs laissé parler les cartes les
cartes les coûts d'emprunt car être le
mien je vous demanderai de battre les
cars devraient quatre fois ce sont bien
les mélanges
bien mettre votre énergie un peu aubry
et surtout au poker
au caire
voilà voilà
le flat tax est présent parce qu'on ne
va pas rater les coureurs de thon rouge
et donc sur la marmite dans ce sens pour
toi 90 secondes et donc nous allons
prendre neuf cars 2
3 ja
donc la réponse à des questions
fondamentales professionnelle la réponse
immédiate est la suivante saliver vous
allez progresser
il n'ya progrès évidents
certaines sphères qui vous retiennent un
petit peu en ce moment à l'heureuse mmm
et le progrès et assurer une réponse
positive agitée avec prudence
et avec
prudence et attention aux détails mais
je pense le contrat était surviendrait
assuré en notre faveur
à quoi vous attendre dans le futur et
les via la réconciliation cette version
l'éclaircissement la réconciliation qui
découlera de discussion viviani
il y aura beaucoup d'opposition mais je
pense que cette opposition va former une
fusion est une réponse positive il ya
progrès à éclaircir
dans ma bonne foi c'était vraiment dans
l'avenir
la troisième carte à licques les
facteurs caché subconscient c'est à dire
ce qui se passe au fin fond des choses
encore des gains le prend très mal et
flâner
victoire assurée qui viendra du beaucoup
de conflits certainement mais la
victoire est là la victoire en chantant
des diables
la séance de tirs 2 passes et c'était
l'idéal pourquoi est-ce que cet idéal ne
se ferait pas le bâti des halles était
en place et le dénouement possible
prudent soyez prudents par le nomic pas
de budget énorme pour commencer hier une
certaine fraîcheur que jackson était un
futur n'est pas beaucoup de pognon c'est
la carte de la gestion c'est à dire la
carte de la gestion intelligente et sage
4 progrès dans le futur
carrément même le besoin d'une certaine
avarie se voir au niveau de l'avarice de
plutôt que d'une généreuse en plus
folichonne paris pour commencer c'est
seulement au départ
en province un peu plus loin à il y aura
une colère beaucoup de caractère
intempestif
est ce que vous de son père et votre
autre connaître ses responsables de ne
pas laisser trop colérique la diplomatie
l'équilibré est à protéger en
progressant dans le futur la chance est
avec vous ma chance aura avec nous
profiter de cette chance fidèles allant
beaucoup de chance on va bien se passer
si vieira c'est tout à fait possible
et la roue de la fortune la roue tourne
et donc de donner naissance à de
nouveaux projets tout à fait valable est
tout à fait positif
les cartes sont extrêmement favorables à
la situation mais de cette manière là où
on apporte une aide en votre faveur de
des licences à langres prochaine